let's tackle a slightly more interesting
division problem so we're going to take
280 and divide it by 5. and i encourage
you to pause this video and try to apply
the technique that we've seen in the
previous video to try to figure out what
280 divided by 5 is
so let's have our go at it so we could
rewrite this we've already seen this as
280 divided by
divided by
5.
so the first question we can ask
ourselves is how many times does 5 go
into 2 well 5 doesn't go into two at all
it goes zero times zero times five
is
zero and then we subtract two minus zero
is two and now we can bring down the
next digit which in this case is an
eight and so we can ask ourselves how
many times does 5 go into 28 without
going over it
so we could think well let's see 5 times
5 is 25
5 times 6
is
30.
so 5 times 6 would go over to 28 so we
would want to go back to 5 times 5.
so 5 goes into 28 5 times
5 times 5 is 25
and you subtract 28 minus 25 is 3 and
now let's bring down the next digit in
this case the digit is a 0. so how many
times does 5 go into 30 well it goes
exactly 6 times we've already talked
about that
6 times 5 is 30. we subtract and we have
nothing we have nothing left over so we
just figured out that 280 divided by 5
is equal to
56.
now why did this work well the first way
to think about it this was actually 200
and we were thinking about do we put
anything in the hundreds place here so
one way of thinking about it how many
hundreds of times does 5 go into 200 and
it doesn't go any multiples of 100 and
if that's a little confusing don't worry
too much about it but i want you to
really think about deeply about the
place notation but then we were able to
again extend it to instead of just 200
but then 280. this 28 right over here if
you think about it this 2 is in the
hundreds place this 8 is in the tenths
place so this is really representing 280
and we said how many tens of times does
5 go into 280 well it goes 5 tens times
or it goes 50 times 50 times 5 is 250.
when you subtract 250 from 280 you got
30. and there was no other things in the
ones place here so we just had to figure
out how many times does 5 go into 30.
so hopefully that gives you a sense of
what's actually happening behind this
little process this little it's not just
magic we're really just keeping track of
place value here the other thing i want
to show you is that we didn't
necessarily have to write this 0 here
another way of computing it we could
have said
divided by
5.
we could have said how many times does 5
go into 2 well it doesn't go any times
so let's just think about 5 go into 28 5
going into 28 well 5 goes into 28 5
times five times five is 25
subtract
28 minus 25 is three
bring down the zero five goes into
thirty six times six times five is
thirty and we have nothing left over and
again what we were really saying is that
5 doesn't go into 2 200 any hundreds of
times if this was a 500 you could say
hey it's going to go in it 100 times but
instead we go well what about 5 going
into 280 well it goes 50 times 50 times
5 is 250 280 minus 250 is 30. 5 goes
into 30 six times so hopefully that
makes a little bit of sense